Salut à tous, c'est Treasure Fisher, aujourd'hui je suis avec mon ami Alex et sa famille
Aujourd'hui, nous allons faire de la pêche à l'aimant dans un endroit nouveau et plutôt compliqué, avec des troncs d'arbres, des rochers et de la profondeur
Mais je pense que c'est un coin où les criminels pourraient se débarrasser de beaucoup de choses
Nous savons qu'ici nous pouvons trouver des armes et des coffres-forts alors allons à la pêche aux aimants
C'est mon premier coup et j'ai déjà quelque chose de lourd
Il y a un morceau de plastique
Oh câble!
Avec un extincteur en cadeau
Le premier lancement est à la hauteur de nos attentes
En plus ce n'est pas un extincteur, c'est une cartouche de gaz
Le tout a été volontairement lesté
Quelle drôle d'idée d'accrocher tout ça ensemble
Je pense que cet endroit sera fou
La bouteille de gaz n'est pas vide
Enlevez-le alors
Avec l'aimant "BARBARIAN", les découvertes sont ici garanties
Qu'avons-nous attrapé
Ok, je ne sais pas, si vous avez une idée, faites-le moi savoir!
C'est léger
Non, rasta ...
Donne-le moi, c'est dégoûtant
J'ai quelque chose de lourd
Regarde, ça ressemble à un morceau de voiture
Ce n'est pas mal du tout
Ça va, ce tole est léger!
Quelle est cette clôture?
C'est une clôture d'appât
Ahh, super un porte-manteau!
Vous avez besoin d'aide ?
Un joli cadre de scooter
Tout neuf
Les objets sont mieux conservés ici que dans le canal qui est plein de boue.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Je pense que c'est vide mais vérifions
Je ne sais pas
C'est un changement de vitesse
On dirait que Rasta le chiot veut te manger le dos
Nous allons essayer de lancer l'aimant un peu plus loin pour attraper les objets légers qu'ils ont pu lancer
ça bouge, viens!
Je prends une petite partie de la voiture et j'arrive
Serioulsy?
Oui
c'est le même
Vous avez peut-être aussi un rôle
Ça bouge, l'aimant monte mais ça ne vient pas
Avec un coup rapide, vous pouvez caler dans le pire des cas, mais vous pouvez tout avoir!
c'est un peu sportif aujourd'hui
Regarde le carburant
Avec un coup rapide, vous pouvez caler dans le pire des cas, mais vous pouvez tout avoir!
C'est tellement bon!
Nous mettons le treuil manuel
Cela devrait nous aider à le sortir de la branche qui le piège
ok nous sommes prêts maintenant
ça va aller
C'est un scooter ou un cyclomoteur,
Oui, l'aimant peut tirer 1600 kilos donc il devrait venir!
Mais 1,6 tonne, c'est sur papier, hors de l'eau et pour la fonte
J'ai déjà vu des vidéos sur Internet mais les voir en vrai, c'est génial
Nous l'avons
celui-ci est lourd
C'est bloqué ici, nous tirerons de ce côté
C'est le tronc d'arbre en haut qui nous dérange
Ok donc c'est un cyclomoteur! Génial
Cela semble très bien!
Attendre attendre
Il doit être attrapé par l'arrière
Celui-ci est assez vieux
Bien fait
FIAT, super!
C'est la première fois que nous en avons un aussi ancien en si bon état
Qu'as-tu trouvé? Une bande!
It's Michel Sardou !
Michel Sardou! Vous devez garder cela en souvenir
Il y a aussi un nom, peut-être le propriétaire, Pascal Perez
It's a peugeot 104
Là vous avez le logo Peugeot, puis là vous avez Fiat?
J'espère que je pourrai l'attraper, j'ai fait une découverte folle qui est tombée
Allez je vais l'avoir quand même j'ai un aimant BARBARE
oui oui ça vient
Ne t'accroche pas à mon aimant
Oh non non
Oui oui ...
Ça vient en fait
Je pense que c'est une bonne
N'est-ce pas un PC gamer?
Oui c'est le cas
Whoaa!
Un ordinateur portable gamer
" République des joueurs"
C'est un Asus et c'est magnifique!
Tout neuf !
Un ordinateur comme celui-ci, ça coûte 2000 euros neuf
le joueur vous le dira
Pour moi ça coute 2000 euros, c'est un i7
Quelle bonne nouvelle, je dois changer mon ordinateur portable
ça va être dur
Nous verrons ce que nous pouvons en tirer, mais cela ne me semble pas si vieux non plus!
Je le fais pour vous pour 50% du prix
Intéressant ;)
Voici ce que Quentin vient de recevoir, un PC gamer à 2000 balles dans le plus grand calme
Juste ça
J'aimerais savoir ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur!
Je pense que ce sera compliqué d'exploiter les composants
Ouverture du PC à la fin de la vidéo
1100 euros refurbished
Peut-être pouvons-nous trouver le propriétaire avec le numéro de série?
Quelque chose arrive! Probablement une autre pièce de voiture
Qu'est-ce que c'est, 44 Magnum?
Ouais 44 Magnum ça
Peut être 45 ACP
C'est ce que j'allais dire
Ouais c'est ça
Donc c'est la munition que nous avons trouvée
C'est 45 ACP
Ils sont tous de 1942
So WW2 munitions
Ils sont entièrement en métal et la veste est endommagée à cause de l'eau
Cette munition peut avoir été utilisée pour les Colt 1911
Mais ce n'est pas le cas, je connais les gens qui y ont trouvé l'arme
Vous ne le croirez pas mais c'était un véritable:
Thompson
Celui-ci est bien sûr une réplique
Les gens qui en ont parlé m'ont montré des photos
Il était assez bien conservé, donc je pense qu'il a été jeté bien après la seconde guerre mondiale
Il y avait un magazine plein et un magazine vide avec
Bravo à eux pour cette superbe arme emblématique des années 30/40
Soyez prudent Rasta!
Tu es un peu au milieu mon garçon
Oh ouais du cuivre!
On aime ca
Une belle bobine
C'est assez lourd!
J'ai quelque chose!
Oh ouais un leurre de pêche!
Un troisième cadre de moto? Ouais c'est ça. Allons-y !
Qu'est ce que c'est maintenant?
Le moteur ?
A Solex motor
Oh merde !
Bien sûr, nous en avions besoin
L'amortisseur! Il y a aussi la ceinture!
J'ai un gros truc. Je pense que le quatrième!
Ouais ouais ouais
En effet
Tu l'as annoncé, c'est l'autre partie je pense
C'est l'autre partie
Ce n'est pas si vieux
C'est un nouveau
Je pense que c'est une caméra
Oui c'est un vieux Kodak
Est-ce une partie de la voiture blanche?
Oh non
Il y a quelque chose à l'intérieur?
Y a-t-il quelque chose dans le sac?
Peut-être une arme
Est-ce une coquille?
Non
C'est de la merde
Allons-y
Oh non, encore une fois ...
Bon pour le ferrailleur
C'est un câble à étirer
On peut aimer les poissons avec ça
Oui tu peux, c'est pour accrocher des bateaux
Il y aura un poids énorme de
Nous ne pouvons pas tout ramener à la fois
Espérons que les gens ne les rejetteront pas entre-temps
Il essaie de pêcher à l'aimant pendant 2 minutes et il a trouvé un moteur de scooter
La chance du débutant
Allez! le 5
Le sac est aussi une bonne trouvaille
Nous allons le remplir
Une nouvelle trouvaille, des leurres de pêche
Et ici, des balles!
Que fais-tu mon garçon?
Un canon de fusil de chasse
C'est assez vieux
Mais la condition n'est pas si mauvaise
C'est une jauge 12
Belle trouvaille
Vous pouvez le conserver avec un permis de tir ou un permis de chasse
À mon avis, il peut encore tirer avec de la poudre noire
Je n'utiliserais pas de munitions récentes
Donc cette vidéo touche à sa fin, nous avons évoqué des trucs très très lourds dans l'Orbe aujourd'hui
Vérifier à la pile
Il faudra plusieurs allers-retours pour intégrer tout cela dans la Polo
Mais nous l'évacuerons et le vendrons au ferrailleur comme d'habitude
Un petit leurre de pêche à la fin
À la prochaine
Comme vous pouvez le voir, tous les composants intérieurs sont morts
Ils sont beaucoup trop rouillés, rien n'est récupérable
Sauf peut-être le plastique et les touches du clavier
Ce sont les seules choses que nous pouvons valoriser